Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa
阿羅漢であり 正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に私は敬礼したてまつる
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa
阿羅漢であり 正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に私は敬礼したてまつる
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato
Sammā Sambuddhassa
阿羅漢であり 正自覚者であり
福運に満ちた世尊に私は敬礼したてまつる
Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
私は仏陀に帰依いたします
Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
私は法（真理）に帰依いたします
Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
私は僧（聖者の僧団）に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
再び 私は仏陀に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
再び 私は法（真理）に帰依いたします
Dutiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
再び 私は僧（聖者の僧団）に
帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Buddhaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
三たび 私は仏陀に帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Dhammaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
三たび 私は法（真理）に帰依いたします
Tatiyam pi Sanghaṃ Saraṇaṃ Gacchāmi
三たび 私は僧（聖者の僧団）に
帰依いたします
Pāṇātipātā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
私は「生き物を殺さない」
という戒めを受けて守ります
Adinnādānā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
私は「与えられていないものを取らない」
という戒めを受けて守ります
Kāmesu micchācārā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
私は「淫らな行為をしない」
という戒めを受けて守ります
Musāvādā veramaṇī
sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi
私は「いつわりをかたらない」
という戒めを受けて守ります
Surāmeraya majjapamādaṭṭhānā
veramaṇī sikkhā padaṃ samādiyāmi.
私は「放逸の原因となり （人を）
酔わせる酒類 麻薬などを使用しない」
という戒めを受けて守ります
では 慈悲の瞑想をいたします
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し念じます
私の親しい生命が
幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが
叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも
悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が
幸せでありますように
親しい生命が幸せでありますように
と繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも
悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますように
ありがとうございます
では よろしくお願いします
今日の法話会ができるようにと
このホールの費用とかを
お布施をして頂いた方々にも
まず幸福でありますように
と感謝いたします
それから協会の方々と
スタッフの方々みんなに
外で待っていたのだけど
色々準備がたくさんあるようで
ボランティアの方々に
みんなに
三宝のご加護がありますように
幸福になりますように
悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
心が清らかになりますように
解脱に達することが
できますようにと
まず感謝いたします
祝福いたします
それから 今日の話に入ります
今日はテーマなくて
喋るようにと
指令されてはいましたけど
それはちょっときついので…（笑）
色々問題が起きてしまって
コロナの関係もありまして
スライドを作ったりすることも
できませんでしたし
スライドは私には作れたのだけど
ここでそれを上映したり
機械をいじったりすることが
ちょっと準備できなくなったので
理解していただきたいと思います
今日 私は業（ごう）について
カルマですね
業についてちょっと
話してみようかなと思ったのです
業について話すと
いろんな方向へ
話が飛んでしまいますし
一般の方々に大体理解できない
範囲に飛んでしまいますので
ある一つの経典を選びました
きっかけは新宿の
朝日カルチャー（教室）で
業の「大分別経」という
経典の（中の）経典という
講義を３回ぐらいに
分けてやりましたけど
かなり難しい内容で
見事に
誰も理解しなかったと
思いますけど
それは私の説明は
大したものではないのだから
理解は難しかったと
思いますけど
結局は経典を説明する注釈書を
書いた偉いお坊様方も
超エリートの方々でしょう
理解していないのです
ですからそこら辺を
説明しようとして
難しくなりました
ですから その関係で私は
業を分別する
「大」の経典ではなくて
「小」の経典を選んでみたのです
日本語の訳は
参考にしていないのですが
私は直接パーリ語で（理解しつつ）
自分なりのいい加減で
間違っている日本語で
意味を説明しますが
皆様に出典を申し上げます
更に専門家の日本語訳を
読んでみて下さい
日本語訳はある決まりの
パターンの中で訳すもので
教理学的な内容には
入らないのです
ですからそれでも
理解は難しいと思いますけど
言葉に言葉を入れ替える
それだけの作業で
中部経典は３つに分けています
（経典の数はそれぞれ）
50、50、50経典で
というと（合計）150ですけど
本当は153経典ありまして
それで最初のセクションは
50経典で
真ん中のセクションも
それでラストセクション
これは Uparipaṇṇāsaと
パーリ語で言います
そちらで経典を全部数えてみると
中部経典の136番目になります
この経典は Vibhagavaggo
というグループに入れてあって
「分析する」という
経典のグループで
そちらに経典は10個あります
その中で５番目
経典にパーリ語でアクセスする方々も
中部経典の３番目のセクションで
136番の経典であると知れば
あるいは業の分別の「小」の経典
「大」ではなくて
この小と大とを分けているのは
それはあんまり意味がないのです
経典に同じ名前を付けてしまうと
だいたい一つは「小」にする
一つは「大」にする
タイトルを付ける場合は
経典を編集した方々は阿羅漢たち
みんな阿羅漢たちが
行ったのです
ぜんぜんタイトルについては
何か付ければ良い
という感じで
何かを付けているのです
しかし昔は暗記するのだから
暗記しなくては
ならないでしょう
この各経典のグループの名前と
タイトルの名前は
まず暗記するのです
そうすると経典を管理する
お坊さんたちがいて
経典を忘れたりはしません
それから繰り返すフレーズを
たくさん入れるのです
繰り返すフレーズを
たくさん入れると
暗記する場合は
暗唱して...また唱える場合は
ぜんぜん間違いなく
一言も一文字も間違いなく
唱えること
思い出すことは
できます
ですから テキストとして
パーリ語で直接読む時でも
あるいは訳（やく）で
英訳 日本語訳等で読む時でも
これは面倒くさく
なってしまいます
この繰り返すフレーズを...
そうすると
省略したりするのです
省略して読んでみると
結局は分からなくなるのです
そういう訳で
何かややこしいのです
現代の方々に知識的に
楽に読めるように 経典を
新しく翻訳することは
できるのだけど
それは決して...
個人が自分の責任で
自分の研究として
発表しなくてはいけないのです
決して「この経典はこの翻訳」
という風に言うことは
認めないのです
それで なになにさん
なになに教授の...
解説 ということに
なるのです
昔からそういう決まりで
これはブッダの教えをできるだけ
純粋に守るための工夫です
だからといって個人に
自分で自由に研究する
自由もあげているのです
個人がいくらでも
研究してくださいと
だからといって
元の教えに
何もするなよと
それはそのまま
残しておいて下さいと
自分の分析・解説は
自分の名前で責任を持って
やってみて下さいと
これでこの業の分析の経典
これはどちらかというと
一般人向けに喋った
経典なのです
ですから 何となく
一般人が興味あるところは
語ってはいるのです
それである時 お釈迦様が
祇園精舎にいた時です
スバ（Subha）というバラモンで
トーデイヤプッタ（todeyyaputta）
というファミリーネーム（姓）
トーデイヤというバラモン家の人で
スバという名前です
お釈迦様に会って色々しゃべって
普通にしゃべっていて
突然ある質問をするのです
私はその質問を
パーリ語で言います
Ko nu kho, bho gotama,
hetu ko paccayo yena
manussānaṃyeva sataṃ
manussabhūtānaṃ
dissanti hīnappaṇītatā?
お釈迦様 これは何でしょうか？と
人間の間で みんな人間なのに
いろいろ差が見えるのだよと
hīnappaṇītaというのは
優れた人々もいて...
hīnaというのは
「卑しい」という意味で
paṇītaというのは「優れた」で
いわゆるいろいろ上下関係の
人間というのは幸せな人間もいて
不幸な人間もいるのだと
だからそういう風に
質問するためには
スバさんがある程度で
ブッダの教え・文化に
なじんでいる人でなければ
いけませんね
なぜならば バラモン教では
人間は差別システムで
神が作ったのだと
人間に上下関係があるのは
互いに区別あるのは
神がそういうことが必要だから
やったのだよと
だから人間は平等ということは
そんなに
関係ないのです
平等でないことは 当たり前
ということになっていて
しかし お釈迦様が
人間という種（しゅ）が
みんな同じだと
とても力強く説くのです
生命の区別ありますよと
魚たちを見ると
いろんな種類があって
鳥たち 動物たちを見ると
ものすごい種類でしょう
鳥たちでも カラスとスズメが
同じではないでしょうに
食べ方やら 生活習慣やら
交尾の仕方やら
子育ての方法やら
それぞれの種によって
それぞれ違いますよと
そこで人間という種が
当時「ホモサピエンス」という
名前はなかったのだから
当たり前でしょう
最近作ったラベルですから
manussa
という言葉を使います
manussaという言葉はずっと...
インド ヨーロッパ
どこでも同じ言葉です
humanということ
menschlich（ドイツ語）
ということを
manということ
manussaということ
全部同じ
これは man という
「考える心」という単語から
初めにインドというかイランの方で
作られた単語だそうです
6000年ぐらい前に
人間には manussaという...
漢字で見ても
「人」という字でしょう？
「人」という漢字で
黒人か白人か 区別ないでしょう？
そうするともう一つ漢字を
入れなくてはいけないのですね
これは 仏教はとても
シリアスに取るのです
人間は 一種類
なぜ一種（類）かというと
お釈迦様は やっぱり
食べる物 生活習慣...
子孫を作る方法 子育ての方法
あれやこれや...
どう見ても 同じやり方で
やっていますよと
だから はっきり言えば
生物学的に一切差がないということ
そのスタンスで このスバさんが
ブッダに聞くのです
人間なのに
何でこんな上下関係
互いに違うのかと
そこで彼が良く説明します
彼が気になったポイントです
お釈迦様、寿命が短命な人がいますよ
早く死んでしまう
dissanti dīghāyukā
長生きする人もいるのだと
dissanti bavhābādhā
ものすごくいろんな病気にかかって
一生いろんな病気で悩んでいる
病弱な人がいるのだと
dissanti appābādhā
たまに病気にかかるのだけど
死ぬまで健康でいる人々もいます
そこでその人は生まれてから
死ぬまでのことを言っているのです
ときどき健康な人々でも ある年齢で
たくさんいろんな病気にかかる
可能性ありますけど
それなりにそれを治療して
治すこともできるし
治せない病気もあるし
それはそれで
そうではなくて
小さい時から病弱
それで死ぬまで
行ってしまうという
dissanti dubbaṇṇā
見たら 「何だこの人は」と
ひどく醜い
そういう単語はあまり
使ってはいけないのだけど
いわゆる とてもかっこ悪い
人々もいるのだと
dissanti vaṇṇavanto;
かなりかっこ良い人々もいるのだと
dissanti appesakkhā,
何の威力もなくて
そこら辺かどこかで
何かちっちゃく 生活する人もいるし
dissanti mahesakkhā;
何か王様や大臣みたいな感じで
何かすごい迫力ある人間も
いるのだと
そこで誰かが何々大臣になったら
とても迫力あるように見えますけど
その職業をやっている間だけでしょう？
そういうことではなくて
何かどう見ても偉いリーダーシップの
ある性格を持っている人々はいるのです
それから dissanti appabhogā,
なかなか財産がない 貧乏
がんばったからといって
そうはうまくはいかない
反対にすごい富豪もいるのだと
それからとても卑しい低いカーストで
生まれる人々もいます
すごい高いカーストで
それから頭が悪い
何もロクに理解しない
馬鹿がいるのだと
とても頭の良い賢い人々もいるのだ
という風に
本人が観察した人間の差を
説明したのです
それで当然インドの社会だから
これはよくわかるのでしょう?
インドの人を見たら
そんな一人ひとりは似ていないのです
そこで...
これって何なのか？と
何で同じ種類なのに
そういう差があるのかと言えば
動物の中でもその差があるのです
人間の社会ほど派手に見えない
かもしれませんけど
餌はいくらでもある
環境にいる動物もいるし
やっとようやく苦労して
命をつないでいる...
東京に住んでいる
カラスたちみたいに
やっと命をつないでいる
人々もいるのです
上野公園の前にいる鳩たちは
たまたま餌をもらっているのだけど（笑）
だから
動物の中でも「かわいい！」
と思う動物もいるし
「何だ..」と言う感じの
（動物もいるでしょう）
皆さまは良く犬を飼っているでしょう
それぞれの犬は違うでしょう
あるいは人間が勝手に
品種を変えましたけど
でも人の好みによって
「このタイプがかわいい」
「このタイプは気に入らない」
とかいますから
犬の中には 毛が一本もない
種類もいるのだから
私はそれを見ると病気ではないかと
思ってしまうぐらい
でも飼っている人々は
すごいかわいい、かわいいと
飼っていますよ
「この理由は何ですか？」と聞いたら
お釈迦様があるフレーズで
答えるのです
これはお釈迦様がいろんなところで
このフレーズを教えているのです
出家はこれを丸暗記して
毎日唱えなくてはいけない
フレーズなのです
だから 私も丸暗記して
毎日唱えているのです
このフレーズは
Kammassakā, māṇava,
sattā kammadāyādā
kammayonī kammabandhū
kammappaṭisaraṇā.
yaṃ kammaṃ karissati
kalyāṇaṃ vā pāpakaṃ vā
tassa dāyādo bhavissatī
Kammaṃ satte vibhajati yadidaṃ
– hīnappaṇītatāyā
というフレーズなのです
パーリ語では大体三行です
このプリントではニ行半ぐらいです
意味は
「業だよ」と
「生命は業を相続しているのだ」と
「相続」でしたかね
生まれたら自分には
この財産だという感じで
業を相続しているのだと
kammayonī
業が人を生ませるのだと
ですから自分の母親は
母親ではなくて
業なのです
業が生んだのです
要するに業が生命を
作ってしまったのです
kammabandhū
生命の仲間 親戚と言えば
それも業だと
誰かに頼りたければ
助けてくださいと
お恵みをくださいと言いたければ
それも業だと
それで人を上下に区別をすることが
業の仕業だと
そこでこのスバさんが
あのね お釈迦様が
こんな短いフレーズで言われても
俺には理解できないのだと
何を言っているのかと
だから詳しく教えて下さいと言ったら
俗世間の一般人に理解できるように
お釈迦様がそれを分析していくのです
しかし 我々出家は
そんな意味で理解しないのです
もっとかなり難しい意味があるのです
私は昨日何となく頭に浮かんだのは
他宗教の方々は
宗教は何であろうとも
「神」という概念を信じているのです
神の名前はどうでも良いのです
それは人間が勝手に作る名前だから
ユダヤ人は神の名前を
絶対発音してはいけないという
だからYHWHと ローマナイズ
（ローマ字表記）すると
彼らの言語は
あれは母音はないのです
だから発音できないのです
あとどうでもいいのですけど
エホバとかいろいろ好き勝手に
母音を入れて発音するのだけど
ユダヤ人は神の名前は言いません
ユダヤ人たちには何か発音の仕方が
あったでしょうかね
エホバの発音は「ヤホワハ※」だと思います
（※特別なご発音をなさいました）
名前は別にどうでも良いのです
インド人が昔は「ブラフマン」
と言ったし
今は「ラーマ」とか
物語のキャラを使っています
神はそれは一向に構わない
自分をどんな名前で呼んだとしても
普通のキリスト教になってくると
「父親」と言うのです
「気持ち悪い」とかあまり言わない
「勝手にしなさい」と
father と言うのです
どうでも良いのです そんなのは
私が言いたいのは
この概念・コンセプト
神というコンセプトで
何が現れるかというと
神が全部作るのです
そうすると人間であろうか
動物 自然界であろうか
神の勝手で作るのです
そうすると人間が苦労しているならば
（あるいは）幸せでいるならば
これは神が作った人間だから
そのプログラムで生きます
どうにもならない
ヨーロッパの王家あるいは
貴族で生まれる子どもと
すごい奴隷のカーストというか
ヨーロッパでも昔
そういう制度があったのだから
貧困な家で生まれるとか
そこで今はヨーロッパ人は
カースト制度について
ごちゃごちゃ言うのだけど
向こうには派手にありましたからね
インドには未だに厳しくあるし
だからそういうものは全部
神が作った作品だから
そういう風にwide variety
バラエティー豊かで
作ったことになるのだと
それで kammabandhū
例えば神を信仰する人がいるならば
何かしら 神と仲良く
親戚関係を持った方が良いです
困った時に我々は
親戚に頼むでしょう
そこで誰かから助けを求めるならば
神を信仰する方々は
「神」に言うのです
「神様 こういう問題があるのだから
何とかしてください」と
だから宗教によって
その祈りの仕方やら
いろいろ文化的に
すごい差があるのだけど
基本フォーマットは同じです
If you have a problem, ask god.
それだけです
もし問題があったら神に頼んでみて
「頼む」とは言わないね
「祈って下さい」と
それに「神」という言葉を
仏教で入れ替えて
「業」という言葉に
入れ替えているのです
そこで我々人間にとっては
我々の差別世界 区別世界
良く分かります
それで貧乏な人でも豊かになりたいと
思うのだけど なかなかならない
豊かになるように生まれた人は
使っても使っても使いきれないぐらい
金があるわあるわ キリがなくね
今インターネット・IT世界で
恐ろしい金持ちの
いろんな人がいるでしょう
そういう人々は金が儲かりたい
と思わなくても
流れてくるわ くるわ
面倒くさいのです
だからお金があって面倒くさい
と思う人々もいるのです
これはどうにかならないかと
もうちょっと１万円でも
すぐ給料が上がったら
何とか間に合いますと
泣いている人もいる
給料に月々１万円ぐらいでも
プラスしてもらえばとか
そこに「神」という言葉を入れても
どうすることもできなくなるのです
ブッダはそちらに「業」
ということを入れているのです
ということは「業」というのは
「行為」という意味にも訳します
だから二つあるのです
自分の行為によって結果が出る
そんなことは誰だって知っている
そういうのは難しくはない
だから貧乏な人でも
いろいろ行為をして
豊かになることはあるのです
豊かな家族で生まれた人も
自分の行為によって
貧乏のどん底になる結果を
作ることも可能です
だからその程度の行為は
我々はだいたい知っています
それにも「業」と言うのです
しかしもう一つあるのですね
「業」という...
何か自分には
アクセスできないのだけど
自分の人生のフォーマットを
作っているのです
それが変えられません
一番単純なことは
私は男に生まれたのだから
男であることは
どう頑張っても変えられません
現代人がいろいろ身体をいじったり
それでも男は男なのです
遺伝子は変えられませんから
男であること 女であること
遺伝子が言っているのだから
施術したからといって
どうにもならない
それから自分が男か女か
良く分からない人々もいるのです
それで社会がガチャガチャ
何を言っても意味がないのです
その本人の実感というのは
変えることはできないのです
女で生まれたのに男だと
思っている人もいるし
男で生まれたのに自分が女だと
そういうのは
社会で差別して批判して
あれやこれや弾劾したりして
ものすごい恐ろしいことなのです
どうしようもないのです
それは変えられません
私には私の色を変えられますかね？
もうちょっと１センチぐらい
背が伸びた方が良い
と思ってしまうのだけど
伸びませんね
そこでヴィールスや細菌等に
弱い体質で生まれる
ヴィールスの中にいても
全然へっちゃらな人もいるし
それで自分の管轄と違って
生まれてから自分の仕事を
変えたり 勉強をしたり
商売を変えたりして
好きな道を歩めますよ
音楽家になったり 医者になったり
弁護士になったりとか
それも業なのです
生まれた子供が
弁護士になりたければ
業によって弁護士になるのです
それって分かり切っていること
自分でコントロールできる
何を勉強するのかと
どんな大学のどんな学部に入るのかと
そこで自分で決めて
自分の将来を築くことは
可能でしょう
それは仏教でガチャガチャ
説明する必要はないのです
良く分かりきったことで
しかしこの「私」という
実体・存在は
どうにもならないという
あるパターンで生きているのです
それも業なのです
そこで私たちは誰かに頼む
助けて下さい
困っているのだと
仏教は「業に頼んでください」なのです
業は人ではないのだから
一つのエネルギーですから
自分でエネルギーを
調整することになるのです
では 業を変えてみるぞと
例えば 荒っぽい性格で
何をやってもうまく行かないとか
仕事を見つけても
すぐクビになるとか
結婚しても１年以内で
離婚するとか
「ああ 何だこの不幸は」とか
自分に子どもがいても
子どもが「会いたくない」
と言う場合は
面白くないね その場合は
仕事を見つけても
早くクビにされてしまうとか
それで神社とか教会とかに行って
神様にオーダーを出しても
何もない
何もやってくれないのです
仏教ならば 自分の業に
オーダーを出してみてくださいと
そこで本人が管理できない
どこか業があるでしょう
それは知っている人から学んで
何で私はこうなるのかと
あなたの性格が悪い
あなたに落ち着きがない
何であろうとも良く当たる
ケンカをする
だからあなたは落ち着くことを
訓練してはどうですかと
怒らないことを訓練したら
どうですかと
笑う練習をしたらどうですかと
人を非難することではなくて
苦労してでも人をほめること
評価することも
今日からやってみてくださいと
やってみたら大体
２～３週間１か月間で
好転しますよ 人生は
それが業なのです
自分が自分の業を
ちょっと調整したのです
韓国とかみんなやっている...
plastic surgeryは
日本語で何と言いますかね？
（会場の方→美容整形）
美容整形
韓国ではカッコ悪い女も
カッコ悪い男もまずいないね
日本はそんなに気にしないのだから
たまに誰かがやるかもしれませんけど
美容整形とは何をするのですか？
産まれる時に
自分がもらった身体を
ちょっといじって形を変えるのです
それで自分にも何か
自信がついてしまうし
周りの反応も変わってくるのです
だから美容整形でも
あれは物質的にできるのだから
単純だけど
業を変えたのです
だから生きる上で
人々の性格というのは
決定権だから
性格は業によって
成り立つのですよ
だからアクセス不可能な
ように見える
でも勉強して
性格を改良すると
悪いものであっても
いくらかうまく行くという
そのセクションもあります
またいろんな業の...
またたくさんあります
業というのは
仏教では宇宙を全体的に
物質と心との
二つに分けているのです
だから純物質でできている
宇宙がありますね
その場合 物理法則で
世界は変化しているのです
それは簡単に科学で
簡単ではないのだけれど
科学で説明することも
数学でこうなります
と言うこともできます
例えば太陽はいつ爆発して
なくなるのかと言えば
一応計算してあります
しかし
地球上で人間は
いつ全滅になるのかと
科学者に聞いてみたら
あなたは太陽の寿命まで
知っているのだから
人間というのは
そんな大したことない...
太陽に比較すると...
これは言えないね
他宗教では
良く頑張ったのです
「世紀末」という
Apocalypseという概念ですけど
それを教えて
これでみんな終わりだと
笑っちゃいます
そんなできませんよ
初期時代のキリスト教の方々は
その時 20人 30人の間で
人類は滅びると
計算していたのです
日にちを延期して
延期して...
まだ新しい日にちを
考えているでしょうね
だから彼らが真理を知らないのだから
しょうがないのだけど
仏教は宇宙というのは
物質法則と心の法則であって
変化するのだと
だから我々生命は
今 肉体を持っているのだから
物質でしょう
物質は宇宙法則で変化します
しかしその変化の道を
変えるのです
心が割り込んで
それはすごい簡単なことで
例えばガラスが落ちて
あるいは私はガラスを割ったら
割れたままです
ガラスの破片は
「これはあかん」と言って
また破片全部飛んできて
決まった位置に入って
元のガラスになることは
絶対ないね
我々の身体にどこか怪我とか
包丁で切られたとすると
どうなる？
修復するのです
これは摩訶不思議なこと
物質に何でそんな？
物質にはそんな
気持ちがないのに
身体は物質で
できているでしょう？
でも怪我したらサーッと
怪我は簡単に分かることで
手当しなくても治ります
あるいは我々は薬を飲んだり
いろんなことをやったり
それは何でしょうかね？
だから物質と違って
壊れたくない気持ちと
Reproduce 再び作る
という何かしらの
エネルギーがあるのです
人間というのは
自分が年を取ったら
自分の肉体はReproduce
できないのだから
どうしても衰えて
亡くなるのだから
子孫を作ってしまう
何のために子孫を作るのですかね
結局は
得るものは何もないでしょう
子孫がいたからといって
変でしょう？
でも「子孫を作りたい」という
この衝動が...
大変なものですよ
それは自分の命がなくなる
ということは
心は認めたくないのです
だから Reproduce
新たに作りたいのです
だから若者やら
子どもたちやら
全然子孫づくりだと
思っていないのです
ある年齢になってくると
「ああ 作らなくては」
ということになるのです
だからそういう風に物理学では
まるっきり説明できない
命の営みというものが
ありまして
それが心の法則というし
心の法則は「業」という
フォーマットで働くのです
ですから「業」というのは
宇宙法則でもあります
だから生命は地球だけ
ではないでしょうに
無数にいるのです
宇宙は無限・膨大でしょう？
生命もいますよ それぐらい
だから仏教的に
「全知全能の神」と言ったら
笑っちゃいますよ
「この馬鹿 何考えているのか」と
「この偉大なる存在のことを
知らないのかい」と
それも「業」ということに
なるのです
だから 業というのは
いろんな顔を持っていて
個人になってくると
自分が物質と心で
出来ているのです
そこで心を回転させるのは
業です
心が回転することによって
物質の変化も変わるのです
そこで 我々には
もし理解能力があれば
心は物事を理解するのだから
理解能力があれば
理性があれば
この流れるパターンを
より良いパターンにちょっと
入れ替えることもできます
しかしそれも法則に従って
法則を理解している人
にしかできないのです
「３センチ背が伸びろ」と
言っても伸びません
１キロぐらい体重減らしなさいと
自分の身体に言っても
（身体は）減らしませんね
だから口で言ったからといって
意味がないのです
いつでもフォーマットを理解して
そこでどこで抵抗を得られるのか
というところを
考えなくてはいけないのです
それは業の話です
ちょっと難しい
俗世間では「業ってそういうものだ」
とは思っていないのです
「運命」だと
思っているのです
そんな単純に一般人に
一単語で理解できるもの
ではないのです
宇宙法則なのです
だから我々一人一人
自分の人生を見ると
自分が好きであろうか
嫌であろうか それに関係なく
あるパターンで
あるフォーマットで
命が流れているのです
いくらか変えられますけど
すべて変えることは
できないのです
それで衰退することも
変えられないのです
それも一つ
これは心と物質
両方の法則になります
エントロピーという...
エントロピーでしたっけ
いろいろ それぞれ
単語は変わりますけど
エントロピーは
一応あるのです
どうにもならない
これは心にもあるのです
いくらか
ですから老いることは
避けられないし
システムが壊れることも
心は物質を...
無理やり捕まえて
そちらに住んでいるのだから
借り家はどうですか？
引越ししなくては
いけないのです
生命は 例えば
純鉄 純金 純銀とか
あるいはプラチナとか
そういう一つの物質で
できているならば
衰退ということは
それほどないのですけど
あるのだけど
我々と同じように
激しくはないのです
プラチナは50年経ったら
とてもボロボロになってとか
それはありえないのです
しかし身体はそうではなくて
簡単に壊れるように
たくさんの物質が
組み立てているのです
だから簡単に壊れるのです
何でそう組み立てられたのか
というと
心に（とって）
仕事をする場なのです
だから心は自分に
仕事ができるように
物質を組み立てて
しまったのです
これが簡単に壊れるのです
そこで心は壊れることは
嫌なのです
それで愚かな人間が
子孫を作れば
自分が永遠不滅だと
勘違いして
自分の子どもは
自分ではないのにね
だから宇宙法則として見ると
変化しながら 変化しながら
変化しながら...
限りなく変化しながら
続くのです
仏教でいう輪廻転生というのは
そういうことなのです
単純に「私は死んでどこに
生まれ変わりますか」という
そんなことではなく...
ものすごく...
超越した智慧で
理解する話です
なかなか話が分かりにくい所まで
進んでしまいましたが
経典に戻ってみましょうか
あのフレーズの意味は
その意味なのです
あなたに頼るところは
業しかないよと
しかし 業が神ではないのだから
業に頼る方法は
結構複雑です
仏教でそれを教えているのです
そこでこの若い人...
若いか スバさんの歳を
聞いていないのですけど
māṇavaというのだから
ある程度で若い人でしょう
真剣・真面目な質問をするのは
だいたい若い人々なのです
そこで お釈迦様が
「はい 分かりました 説明します」と
一般的に理解できるように
説明していくのです
そこで「若者」とお釈迦様は
その人を呼ぶのです
Idha, māṇava,
māṇavaというのは
人という意味でもありますけど
だいたい「若い人」という
意味で使うのです
ある男か女は
pāṇātipātī hoti
殺生するのだと
luddo いわゆるすごく残酷
優しさの反対
性格的に残酷
lohitapāṇi
もう血まみれで気にもしない
それで気分が良いのです
生命を殺したら生命から
チャーッと血が飛びかかって
からだ中 でも
気分が良い
hatapahate
いつでも何か武器を持って
刀とか何か持って
殺しだけをやっているのです
niviṭṭho adayāpanno
優しさというのは
ひとかけらもない
pāṇabhūtesu
すべての生命に対して...
優しくない
かなり残酷なタイプ
これで言っているのは
誰かを殺すという行為よりも
その人物の性格なのです
それをこの若者が理解したか
どうか私は分かりません
そういう性格の人がいる
いるんですよ 世の中で
残酷で 優しさは
ひとかけらもない
私は子どもたちを見て
ちっちゃい１歳ぐらいで
何とか身体が動ける状態で
その中でもアリとか見ると
見つけてはつぶす
見つけてはつぶすと
やめさせるのは
大変なのです
また（別の）
子どもたちがいます
アリがどこかへ行くのを
じっと見ているのです
アリちゃんが
どこに行くのかい？とか
そういう...だからすごく
性格がそれで違うでしょう
それは改良しないと
そのまんま
生まれてくると
持ってきた
プレインストールした
プログラムだから
そこを改良しないで
バージョンアップして
新しいOSを
インストールしない限りは
このまま 楽（らく）ちんで
行くのです
生まれた時 インストールした
プログラムだから
これは生まれるということは
遺伝子が組み合わさる時は
生まれたのでもうしょうがない
できあがってしまったのです
お腹・母胎から外へ
出た時ではないのです
そこでお釈迦様が
その人がその自分の性格で
その哲学で生きているのだと
たくさん殺すことにしましょうと
これぐらい殺したよとか
軍人たちとか戦争とかの場合は
これぐらい殺したよと
そのような性格で
一生生きたら その人は
死後はものすごい落ちるのだと
輪廻として
不幸に 地獄に
不幸な所に落ちますと
すごい苦しまなくては
いけない状況に
そういうフォーマットに
なるのです
だから自分の業が...
すぐにその結果を出すのです
だから波というのは
上がったら下がる
宇宙法則だから
それは決まっているのです...
決まっているのではなくて
その波は読めるのです
もしその人は
究極の不幸な所に陥って
生まれ変わらなかったならば
人間になったとしましょうと
人間になったら その業には...
寿命がないのです
命をつなげる力がないのです
だから早く死ぬのです
それはとても
分かりやすい例なのです
一般の方々の誰にでも
ですからこの世の中で
一歳で死ぬ 三歳で死ぬ 七歳で
十歳で ニ十歳でいろいろという
やっと十五歳まで延びた
という方々もいるでしょうに
この方々の身体を
作っている業には
八十年 百年
これを維持管理できる力がないのです
だから遺伝子が組み合わさる時は
そのような 組み合わせになるのです
だからそれは心のしわざであって
心が回転するのは
業のエネルギーですから
業のしわざだよと
反対に
ある人がもう殺生はしない
武器は持たない
そんな考えもない
ピストルでも買おうかなとか
身を守るためにとか
（それも）ない
それで
生命に対して すごく
優しいのです
「あ！ 生き物だから
生きているでしょう」
要するに英語では
Respect for life
命をとても大事にする性格
命ならどんな命にもすごく優しい
誰にだって生きる権利ありますよと
そういう人々は 死後
とても良い所に回転しますと
幸福溢れるところに回転しますと
そこでそういう人々は
人間という形になる場合は
ものすごく寿命が長いのだと
命を守ったのだから
自分の命は守られている
エネルギーがあるのです
それも生まれる時は
決定してしまうのです
そこでもう一人の
性格の人がいるのだと
生命をいじめる
殺すことまで行かない
蹴ったり 踏んだり
石を取ったらもう
何か生命に当てて（と）投げたり
ケガさせたり
ぶん殴ったり いろいろ
これが好きなのです
その人はその性格プログラムで
ずっと生きてきたならば
死後は不幸に陥る
人間になったならば
病弱
いずれは病気
だからそこで法則は
他の命に邪魔したのです
殺すことをしなかったのだけど
命をいじめたのです
そこで相手の命が
迷惑を受けたのです
これで良くみんな
誤解するところがあります
たまたま自分の人生で
人をいじめたことがありましたよ
ということではないのです
これはもう根本的に性格的に
いじめっ子
いじめることが
とても快感で
もうやめられないのです
そうやってこの全体的な
プログラムを言っているのです
我々に聞いたら
あなたは誰かをいじめたことは
一度もないのか？と聞いたら
結構ありますよね
あなたはそういう性格ですか？
と聞いたら
そうでもないね
そこで
フィルタリングして
純粋に性格に分けてみるのです
でないと科学的な答えを
出せないのです
いじめ好きな性格
生命をいじめて行く
生命に怪我させたり
蹴ったり 踏んだり 殴ったり
邪魔をしたり
いろんな方法で生命をいじめる
そういう人々は
もし人間に生まれ変わったら
どうせ死ぬのだから
物質は壊れるのだから
心はまた新しい物質を
つかまえて
身体を作らなくてはならない
人間という身体を作れるぐらい
エネルギーがあって
人間の身体を作ったとしても
その身体は
病弱ということになる
そこで逆に生命が
意地悪な性格は全くない
いじめる性格の反対は
生命を助けてあげる
協力してあげる
それは性格
そういう人々は
どうせ死後も幸福になるし
人間になったら
すごい健康な体になりますと
そこである人が性格的にすごく...
怒りっぽい
ちょっとしたことで
もうボワンと怒りが爆発する
ほんのわずかな言葉を
言われただけでも
もう怒りが爆発して
もう自己管理できない
状態になる
人はその性格だったら
改良しない前提で
生まれた時の性格で
自然の流れで生きている
ということで
当然悪行為だから
死後地獄に落ちると
あるいは地獄に落ちることは
決定ではないのだけど
人間になったら
醜い身体になるのだと
だから怒りで醜い身体になる
いつだってちょっとしたことで
怒りが爆発する人々が
周りの生命に何か
火を放つような感じなのです
みんなそれで焼けてしまうのです
やけどするのです
だから 自分がやけどした
身体で生まれるのです
反対に怒らない性格
自分を侮辱しても
「まあ別に」という感じで
自分がしゃべる場合は
優しい言葉をしゃべったり
人をなぐさめる方向へ
行くのであって
怒る方向へは行かない
要するに周りがどう頑張っても
怒らせることはできない
私は個人的に知っています
そういう人々は
私も若い頃「何としてでも
この人を怒らせてやろうか」と
いろいろ仲間と計画を立てるのです
怒らないのです
だから逆にとても...
親しくしやすいし
みんなと仲良くするし
その人には敵もいないし
冗談で何かちょっと
怒るようなことをしようと
男どうしで結構
そういうことやりますから
やっても本人は怒りません
だからそういう怒らない性格で
生きている人は
死後幸福になるし
人間になったら
とても美しい...
「美しい」と
言うのですかね
みんなが惹かれる...
肉体を持って生まれるのです
そこである人が...
嫉妬深い性格を持っている
他人の幸福は...
気に入らない
もう我慢できない
例えば誰かが誰かをほめると
何となく気持ち悪くなるのです
誰かの悪口を言うと
「ああそうですか そうですか」と
それを調べて
調べて行くのです
だから他人が商売繁盛すると
もうイライラして
もう耐えられない
我慢できなくなる
社会で人々に人気のある人
がいるでしょう
そういう人々は 有名な人がいると
もう我慢できない
それで悪口を言う
その人とではなくて
自分一人でも
嫉妬で燃える
そこで良く嫉妬で燃える...
嫉妬性格
根本的な性格は嫉妬で
嫉妬というのは他人の幸福はもう
そんな耐えられない
その人はもし人間に戻ってきたら
どうなる？
何の威力もないのです
そこら辺で誰も気にしない
人間になるのです
いるかな？
ああ あなたもいたのかとか
迫力 威力 存在感がなくなるのだと
逆に人々が商売繁盛すると
あの人良くがんばって
ここまでうまく行っていますよと
だから人というのは
生まれた時は家が貧乏であっても
ちゃんと頑張れば
誰にだって
成功しますよとか
他人をほめるとすぐそれに乗る
いわゆる嫉妬の反対
そういう性格の人々は
死後天界に生まれるし
人間になったならば
かなりパワーを持っている
人間になるのです
いわゆる かなり人気者
みんなに好かれる人間
迫力のある人間に
リーダーシップのある
人間になるのです
そこで（他の）性格があります
自分のものはいかなる場合でも
他人に分けない
これは私のものだからとか
お布施性格はまるっきりない
自分のものは全部握りしめて
あげません 誰にも
あげたら自分の財産が減るのだよと
貧しい人がいても
ご飯を食べられなくて
お腹が空いている人がいても
あげません
俺の弁当をあげたらって...
あげませんよと
あなた弁当を二つ
持っているでしょう？
ああ二つ持っています
今これは昼食べて
これは夜食べますと
これあげたら？って
夜 私はご飯がなくなって
しまいますから
あげません
これは性格的に 自分のものを
他人にあげること
気に入らない できない
そういう人々は
生命に良いことを
していないのだから
不幸に生まれ変わる
人間になったら
貧乏のどん底になるのです
だから豊かか貧乏かというのは
世間から幸福が来るでしょう？
金持ちの人がいると言っても
その金は自分のもの
ではないでしょう？
世界から来たものでしょう？
だからあげる性格はまるっきりない
物惜しみみたいな感じで
（そういう）性格の人は
人間に生まれ変わったら
なかなか富（とみ）が
自分の方に来ないのです
いくら頑張っても
来ない
そこで逆に
何でも自分のものは分けて
どうですか どうですかと
例えば知識的に
勉強したならば 周りにも
「あなたこれを知っている？」
「これを教えてあげる」とか
教えてあげたり
お金があったら
「一緒にご飯食べましょう」
と言ったり
自分のアパートも友だちに
「あなたも使ってください」とか
そうやって分けてあげたり
例えば 東京のワンルームマンションや
アパートに住んでいても
地方の友だちに
「大丈夫 大丈夫
私の家を勝手に使ってください」
「私のアパートを
（勝手に使ってください｝」とか
そうやって自分のものを
分けてあげる性格
これは性格です
行為単位ではないのです
そこを良く気を付けて下さい
行為単位で物惜しみの人も
仕方がなく何かあげる
羽目になる場合がある
例えば税金を納めなくては
いけないでしょう
いくらけちん坊であっても
だから これは行為ではなく
性格のことなのです
それで分けてあげる性格
の人にとっては
人間に生まれ変わったら
富が来るわ 来るわ 来るわ
自分を探してくる
日本語でも良くフレーズがありますね
金がある所に金が来るのだと
聞いたことがありますよ
金があると金が集まるのだと
やっぱりそのフレーズを作った方々は
何となく観察したでしょう
もともとお金がある人なのに
何をやってもまたお金が増える
簡単に増える
それは前の業で性格を
決めてしまったのだから
行為の結果に現れるのです
そこでまた人がいるのです
ものすごく頑固で我が強くて
いわゆる何と言いますか
人に挨拶しない
尊敬するべき人は
尊敬しない
頭を下げるべき人に
頭を下げません
お世話をするべき
目上の相手ですけど
誰がこんなことをやるのかと
やらない
というぐらい 頑固
頑固と言うのですかね
自我が強いのです
自分だけ偉いと
思っているのです
ほめるべき人はほめない
挨拶する（べき）人に
挨拶しない
頭を下げるべき人に
頭を下げない
そんな固さ
それは人間になったら
何になるのですかね
カーストが低い所に
行くのです
だからプラス・マイナス法則で
自分が頭を下げなかったのだから
生まれ変わったら
誰も自分に頭を下げないのです
誰も頭を下げてはいけない
環境で生まれるのです
それは低いカーストで
生まれるのです
そこで社会的に
私はカースト制度を
認めるわけではないのだけれど
人間は平等だと思ってはいるのだけど
いろんな人々と付き合いあるでしょう
だから社会ではちょっと立場がないとか
カーストは低いとかと思われる人々の間で
何か過去世のクセが見えてくる
とても頑固
もうとても頑固
人を馬鹿にするとか
（私は）ある誰かと個人的に
知り合うことになったら
私はこの性格を変えてやるぞと
変えてみたのです
性格を変えたら...
低いカーストに生まれたことは
問題にならなかったのです
みんなでとても仲良く
することになったのです
それでその人はとても
幸せになりましたけど
ただちょこっと過去世の性格を
調節してあげたのです
こうしなさいと
そこで道徳を守って
行儀作法を守って
目上の人にそれなりに尊敬して
智慧のある人に
それなりに尊敬して
滑らかな人格だったら
そういう人々は生まれ変わったら
かなり高いカーストに生まれるのだと
最後に
何で人は馬鹿で生まれるのですかと
それはやっぱり人間にいる場合は
勉強することは大嫌い
知識を得ることは大嫌い
それで人から学ばない
ああ嫌だ こんなのはとか
言って ふざけて生活する
学校などでは良くそういう
男の生徒の場合良く見られますね
先生を馬鹿にする
勉強大嫌い
その代わり裏で遊ぶ
特に
人はどのように生きるべきか
善悪は何ですかと
生き方について
学ばなくてはいけない
数学は嫌いだったらやめる
それは構わない
なぜならば数学は嫌いだけど
その人は 絵描きは
好きかもしれませんね
それはそんなに
性格的な問題ではないのです
人間にはややこしい勉強を
嫌いになる権利もあります
しかし人間には
正しい生き方を学ぶことは
やらなくてはいけないのです
それは必修科目
悪は何ですか 善は何ですか
それを学ばない
そんなのはどうでも良いやと
例えば 盗んでもバレなければ
大丈夫でしょうという哲学で
盗みが悪いのは
「バレたならば」なのです
犯罪が悪いのは
「見つかったならば」なのです
だから善悪を知っている人は
見つかろうが
見つからなかろうが
犯罪をおこさないでしょう？
そういう性格の人々
いわゆる生き方を学ばない
善悪を学ばない
私はどんな生き方をすれば
幸福になりますか
不幸に陥るのかとか
そういう智慧のところは
勉強しない
それで現代の...
というか私は日本に来た時からも
あったのだけど
そのセクションが
カットされているのです
良い人間になるということは
ただ日本人が元々道徳ある
良識ある国だから
問題起きなかったのだけど
誰もあんまり道徳を気にしない...
日本になったということで
それで頭が悪くなりますよ
だから人間に生まれ変わってしまうと
とても無智で生まれるのです
逆に真理は何なのか
正しい生き方は何なのか
善悪って何なのか
そういうことを学ぶ人々は
死後とても頭が冴えている
智慧の人になります
と言って これで
すべてのあの人の質問に
お釈迦様は答えて終わったのです
そういうことで人間の差が...
業のしわざだよと
「業」というのは
「神」と似ている
単語を使ったのだけど
「個人」が行うのです
「個人」の性格なのです
だから我々は気を付けないと
自分に心があるのだけど
自分のプライベートの財産だと
思わない方が良いのです
自分の心と思考は
それは宇宙法則の一部なのです
だから宇宙法則によって
管理されるのです
我々は地球の上に生きているでしょう？
だから地球は回転すると
自分も回転するのです
「地球が回っても 俺が回りたくない」
とはできませんね
一番昔に「地球は丸い」と言ったら
丸い球を作って
例えば ヨーロッパとかの人々が
「え⁉ 何でオーストラリアの人は
落ちないのですか！」と
と言うこともあったのだけど
オーストラリアの人にも
空は上で
地球は下なのです
丸いということは関係ないのです
それは相対的に見ると
そういう錯覚を起こすだけで
だから我々は地球にいるのだから
地球の法則から抜けられないでしょう？
例えば 環境を汚染したら
みんな それによって影響を受けます
ですから 自分の心も
宇宙法則のほんの一部ということを
理解しないと
だから 正しい生き方を
しなくてはいけないのです
それを発見したのは
ブッダだけだから 仕方がない
こんな風に生きなさいと
お釈迦様は教えているのです
それで仏教が終わるわけではないのです
全部 業を蹴っ飛ばせと
破壊しなさいと
解脱というのは
そういうものなのです
だから仏教は正しい生き方を
教えている訳でもなく
それもやってはいるのだけど
どうやってこの輪廻転生を…
奴隷でしょう？
宇宙法則に従って
地球の法則に従って
従わなくても従うでしょうに
地震が起きたら
「俺が地震は嫌い！」と言って...
意味がないでしょうに
津波は私は大嫌いと
だったら津波が来る時は
あなたを避けて来るのですかね？
結局は
法則だから
だからそんなに法則によって
操られて 操られて
輪廻転生
心は生滅しながらつなげるのです
これは何のありがたみはないのだと
だから脱出しなさい
そこまで教えているのです
生きている間は幸福に生きる
方法も教えてはいるのです
はい
それはスバと言う若者に
お釈迦様が教えた
「業」の話です
ある程度で分かりやすいね
しかし我々の立場で説明すると
ちょっと難しくなります
ここで...
たまに人に嘘を言ったとか
昔 他人をいじめたことありますよと
だから私は死後...
病弱になる...
それはないのです
これはメインのポイントを
言ったのです
全体的な性格ははっきりと
色を分けているのです
青い 白い 黄色いとかね
でも一般人が そうやって
明確な色分けは難しい
嫉妬もするし 怒るし
優しくもなるでしょう？
ハチャメチャでしょう？
何か訳も分からない絵を
描いた画家は誰でしたっけ...
（会場の方→ピカソ）ピカソ
ピカソの作品みたいでしょう？
人間というのは
何も 女か男か...
さっぱり分からないという
目は見つかるのだけど
鼻はまた探さなくてはいけない
この人の鼻はどこにあるのかと
ですから 私たちは
嘘をついたこともあるし
だからといって
嘘つきの人生ではないね
そういうことで 若い時は
ちょっと人をいじめたこともあるし
嫉妬したこともあるし
落ち込んだこともあるし
そういうピカソの絵画みたいに
ハチャメチャ何でもありきですから
ここで明確に
色（いろ）別々で説法したのです
そこで色が混ざったら
どうなるかということは
皆様は ご自分でご判断ください
しかし単位毎に言えば
嘘をついたら
それなりに悪い結果を得る
ポテンシャルを蓄積したのです
友だちから千円ちょっと
あいつにバレないのだから
取りますとか
取ったところで
それも盗みなのですけど
それで地獄に落ちるかというと
そうではなくて
ほんのちっちゃな...
貧乏になるポテンシャルを
顕微鏡で見ても見えないぐらい
小っちゃいものが貯まったのです
だから単位毎に言うと
はっきりします
しかし その一個の行為だけ
ハイライトしてはいけない
死後は...全体的な性格で
どこら辺に重きがあるのか
ということで
次を決めるのです
だからずっと悪人で生きてきた人にも
最後に善人になることは
いたって可能です
私は３０年間
超だらしない生活をしましたと
悪いことばっかりしてきましたと
仕事はやくざでしたと
今は４５歳でどうしようかと
大丈夫ですよ
それから性格を変えれば
だからトータル的な結果も
気を付けた方がよろしいのです
私の人生ってどんなものかなとか
過去を考えたら
「うわ！イヤ もうやりたくない」
と言うぐらい
「美しい」性格だったら
はい これから変えましょうと
あれはすごい善行為ですよ
性格をガクンと変える
オーストラリアで説法している...
(Ajhan) Brahmさんというお坊さんの
説法にあった ある話ですけど
自分の所にある人が修行に来たのだと
この人は何か犯罪をして
刑務所にいた人で
そこで刑務所で仕事をしなくては
いけないのだから
牛を 肉用というのですか...
牛を殺さなくてはいけないのです
だいたいみんなそんなことは
やりたくはないのだから
刑務所の人々は義務的に
仕事をしなくてはならないのだから
そういうところの仕事に出すのだと
そこで牛がいて
電気でパッパッパッと
みんな殺すのです
瞬間で殺すのです
それでこの人も
この仕事に回されてしまって
殺すのです 何の関係もなく
ピシッピシッと
電気ショックで直ちに死ぬ
そこである日行ったら
メス牛がいたのだそうです
そこで自分がそばに行くと
あのメス牛が
泣いているのです
泣いているのを見たら
コイツ（この人）は
何となく心が変わってしまったのです
メス牛だから 所詮
女でしょう 生命として
コイツは男でしょうし
だから もしかすると
母親という感じで
泣いたかも
あの泣いた涙を見て
ボロボロと涙が落ちるのを見て
心が変わってしまって
とても汚い悪い英語で
言葉を言って
「テメエらやりなさい
俺がやらん」と言って
それっきりその人はこの
殺生の仕事をやめたそうです
それからBrahmさんのお寺に来て
修行をしたり 瞑想をしたり
良い人間になったのだそうですという
その人の説法から私が拝借した
ちょっとしたエピソードなのです
ですから
まあ刑務所に入るまでの
乱暴な性格でしょう？
ちょっとしたことで変わって
修行する羽目になる
ということがありえるのです
その人が死ぬことになってくると
どちらが優先になるのですかね？
自分が変わったこと
良い人間になったことは
かなり迫力ある（ように）
感じられるでしょう？
そういうわけで
この経典の説法は
悪用しないでください
あなたは動物・生命を
殺してしまったのだから
地獄に落ちるんだぞとかね
あなたは身体障がいで
それほど長生きできそうもない？
（だとしたら）あなたはカッコつけて
こういうことをやった人でしょうとか
これは恐ろしいことなのです
差別しないでください
差別することは
「自分が偉い」と思うことでしょう？
それはこのリストにあったでしょう？
不可触民族として生まれるのです
これは他に今は単語がないのですよ
カースト制度がなくても
そういう誰も相手にしない人間
いくらでもいるでしょうに
だからこの話は
悪用して人を差別するために...
絶対使わないこと
これは差別するために
言っているわけではないのです
宇宙の法則を語ってはいるのです
とにかく行為に結果がある
これはどうしようもない
誰のせいでもない
行為が結果を出す
神も悪魔も割り込む必要はないのです
そこで一回嘘をついて
人をだましたことがある場合は
必ずそれによって自分が...
嘘をつく人は 全く人に
信頼されない人間になるのです
過去世で嘘をついた人が
人間になってすごい知識人になって
論文を書いても
みんなそれを却下するのです
ケチをつけてしまって
それは大したことないと
だから
信頼されない 認められない
という運命になるのです
ですから...
一回かなり大きな嘘をついたからといって
それによって こうなる
ということは決められない
なぜならば
結果を出すために
他の条件も揃わなくてはいけないのです
もしその人が性格的にも
他の悪い所が揃っているならば
自分を改良する気持ちはないならば
知ったことではないのです
そのまま結果を出す
悪行為をしても
他にいろんな善行為ばかりしているし
性格も改良しようという努力もするし
そうするとこの悪行為の種（たね）に
実ることはできなくなってしまうのです
でも無効にならない
後回しになるのです
条件が揃ったら 芽が出るぞと
業で理解が難しいところは
そういうことなのです
例えば この世の中で
結構悪い人間が
結構豊かになっているのは
あるでしょう？
プーチンさんも
わがままで 自我を張って
戦争して...
でも プーチンさんを抑えることは
世界の誰にもできませんね
こんな悪いことするなら
すぐバチが当たった方が良い
と思うでしょう？
それは条件が揃っていないのです
ですから
死後は...
分からない
あんなかっこうの性格で
ずっと貫いているのだからね
今は例えば ロシア人が立ち上がって
今 スリランカで
やっているような感じで
「プーチン お前これをやめなさい」
「でなければ 大統領を辞任しなさい」と
言うところまで
ロシア人がまとまりませんからね
面白いことを言います
スリランカで国民は９０％以上...
自分の国で...
大統領に「辞任しなさい！」と
叫んでいるのだけど
辞任しないのです
どこまで頑固かと
今子どもたちに飲ませる
ミルクさえ ないのです
そこで一般人が何かでも
犯罪をおこすまで待っているのです
全部 軍隊を準備して...
でも それは昔の人間...
今はもうインターネットの人間だから
みんな全部知っているのです
だから電気がないことに反対するために
みんな ロウソクとか
あるいは布を巻いて何か作って
夜にこうやって挙げているのです
反対運動をやっているのです
それでも...
何一つも火をつけるような
ことはしないのです
たくさん集まって反対運動をやっても
終わって解散する時は
全部ゴミも拾って
クリーンにして帰るのです
政府に権力を誇示することが
できるならばやってみなさいと
だからインターネットで
話題になった写真があって
警察は大変なのです
あの泥棒たちを守らなくては
いけないのだから
だからものすごいバリケードを作って
じっと捕まっているのです
警察は20人 30人来たとしても
こちらはもう
3000人の人々がいるのだから
あれを押すのです みんなで
それで警察も大変ということは分かって
あまりバリケードを破らないのだけど
ある女の人がバリケードを
持ち上げて 警察の人に
「どうぞ」とバラの花を
一つ差し上げたのです
要するに
「あなた方の苦しみ分かりますよ」と
だから私もびっくりしたのです
今の若者というのは
我々の時代と違って
こいつら超 頭が良いのですね
ふざけて遊んでいるわりに
結構頭が良いのです
今 反対デモをやっているのだけど
歌ったり 踊ったり
そういうことをやっているのです
ですから 警察とぶつかることもなく
政府は待っているのです
全部の軍隊をコロンボに呼んでいるのです
そこで緊急事態宣言をしたのです
それから外出禁止令も出したのです
みんな集まる日を
インターネットで発表するのだから
その日の前から
「外出禁止令だ」と
意味がないのです
みんな行くのです
そこでこの前の日曜...
土曜日かな
大統領の事務所のある所に
大きな公園がありまして
海のところで
そちらで20万人ではなくて...
100万人が集まってもらいますよ
と言ったら
次の日に政府は全部看板を変えて
この公園は修復しますので
立入禁止という看板を...
意味がない（笑）
サーっと人が行って
朝まで反対デモをやったのです
面白いのです 法律はもう...
何か笑っちゃいます
だから軍人に「撃ちなさい」
と命令しても
撃てるかどうか
一般人に向かって
それは問題ですよ
だから...
そこはちょっと雑談的な話で
業に戻りますけど
プーチンさんみたいな
見る限り 性格は他の…
ゼレンスキーさんの性格は
聞いたところで分からないのだけど
日本でアメリカで褒めたたえるのだから
あれも偏見的なことで
どうでも良いのだけど
私にとっては...
あんなに悪人だったら
すぐバチが当たるでしょうって
そう簡単ではないのです
大統領という
あの権力がある限りはもう…
ですから 我々の行った...
悪行為の結果 善行為の結果
というのは
条件が揃ったところで
実るのです
法則だから仕方がないでしょう？
種があるからといって
必ず芽が出るって
ないでしょう？
業の場合も
そういうことなのです
だから仏教で言うのは
たまたま悪いことをやっても
後悔するなよと
これは開き直りではないのです
良くそれを理解して
二度とやらないようにする
後悔すると悪が拡大するのです
そうすると
性格になってしまうのです
悪行為をして 落ち込んだら
それからずっと落ち込んだ性格...
アウト
そういうわけで
毎日善行為をした方が
良いと思いますが
話はそれで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
（拍手）
司会の方）スマナサーラ長老
ありがとうございました
15分ほどお時間がありますので
皆様の質問に答えて頂きたい
と思います
先生よろしいですか...
ご質問ある方は
挙手いただけますか？
はい ちょっとお待ちください
質問者の方）
今日はありがとうございました
仏教を実践しているおかげで
自分のことをずいぶん...
好きというか 良いと思えることが
増えてくるようになりました
ただ先ほどお話にあったのですけれども
馬鹿にされるのが許せないというか
悔しいというか
そこのところはどうしても
ちょっと克服ができなくて
それで集中的に合宿を自分一人で
５日間とか瞑想をしたのですけれども
その時にも
もちろん目的は瞑想すること
なのですけれども
何でこんなに馬鹿にされて悔しいのか
ということをテーマに置いて
座る瞑想 歩く瞑想を
ずっとやりました
それで
相手を「いる」というか
固定したものだと思うから
間違いであって
ただの現象なのに
現象にバカにされて
何で悔しいんだろうって
その時にフッと智慧みたいな
ちょっと分かったような
気がしたのですけれども
日常生活に戻るとやはり
馬鹿にされると悔しい
というところが
どうしても抜けられません
それで 先ほど長老がおっしゃったように
馬鹿にされても
フフッというような人に
私もなりたいですし
ちょっと長老が
過去のクセを変えてあげたら
直った みたいなことを
おっしゃっていたので
私もちょっと変えられるように
ヒントというか教えて頂きたいです
お願いします
長老）これ 問題は
「馬鹿にされている」と思うのは
あなた自身です
そこで苦しくなるのは
あなた自身なのです
それがあなたの業なのです
我々が分からないのは
相手が本当に馬鹿にしているか
どうかなのです
結構私も人を意図的に見下して
いろんなことを言うでしょうに
言ってもそれは
馬鹿にするつもりではなくて
みんなでワイワイと
楽しく笑いましょう
という気持ちですよ
相手がかわいいからこそ
大事だからこそ
何か言うのです
だから
相手が自分を見下して
馬鹿にしているかいないかって
そうは分からないのです
だから我々には
相手の立場になって考える
ということはできないのです
そこで言われることには
主観的に怒るしかできないのです
それで自分の心が
「馬鹿にされている」
という風に翻訳して
じゃあ 落ち込もう
じゃあ 腹が立とう
と言う風な 悪行為の結果を
出すのです
だから そういう仕組みに
なっているのです
ですから...
こう思っちゃえば
それはその人々の性格だと
性格はまあ放っておきましょう
変えられませんよと
それで
放っておくしかないのです
それを
「私はこういう翻訳はしません」と
「私を馬鹿にしている」という風に
翻訳はしないことにすると
もしかするとこれは業で
過去の何かで
そういう落ち込む結果になるし
落ち込んだら
更に悪行為になるのだから
落ち込まないようにします
という風に
ちょっと努力した方が良い
とは思います
これを直す方法は
もうちょっと難しくはなくて...
結構 微妙に...
心にしゃべらなくてはいけないのです
こういうところではできないのです
そのケースを
具体的に知っているならば
私なら読めますから
読んで 「こういう答えだ」
とは言えるし
一般論で言えば
馬鹿にされているのだから
どうせ馬鹿だから
いちいち言う必要ないでしょうと
私もお前と一緒で馬鹿だよと
それでもそれに気づかず
あなたは毎日言うのだから
相当馬鹿ですね
だって馬鹿に「馬鹿！」
と言っても意味がないでしょう？
犬に「犬！」と言ってみて？
馬鹿でしょう？
だからそういう（風に）
ちょっとアプローチを変えれば
本当に相手が
「お前は馬鹿だ 馬鹿だ！」と
はっきりと言う場合は
それは使えるのですよ
「そうよ 私は馬鹿ですよ」と
「それなのにいちいち言う
必要はないや」と
「『お前は女だ 女だ』
と言う必要ありますか？」と
「思い出さなくて良いや」と
「私は女であることを
知っていますよ」と
「忘れませんよ」と
「それでも思い出すあなたは...
...馬鹿さは...
...金メダル並みだ」と
と言う風に言えますよ
私はだいたい問題というのは
ユーモアで軽く取って
生きていれば良いでしょう
すべて無常だから
人の性格というのは
まあ放っておきましょう
そんなに直らない
だから被害を受けることが
自分の業だから
それは自分で変えて下さい
何を言われても
「言論の自由だから勝手に言え」と
「これは無視するのは私の自由だ」と
それだけでしょう？
何で乗るのですか？他人の話に
無視すれば良いでしょう？
無視できるあなたに
その自由があるでしょう？
とにかくできるだけ
ユーモアを使ってください 人生に
はい 以上です
司会の方）はい
ではもう一人ご質問...
質問者の方）
どうもありがとうございました
リーダーであるプーチンさんは
ひどい人であるというのは
例外ではないと思うのです
リーダーたちに性格の悪い人は
いっぱいいます
それから下の方の人たちで
性格の良い人はいっぱいいます
全然例外ではない
という気がしています
例えば 小さい子どもに
痛い注射をする時に
大概の子どもは
「痛い 痛い」と大騒ぎをします
でも 全然...
痛いのだけど
「こんなもんだ」という風に
あきらめるのではなく
何か人格がすごくある
小さい子どもがいます
100人に一人ぐらいいます
かと思えば
頑張って我慢している
痛いのだけど
必死に我慢している子が
100人のうち
10人ぐらいいます
あとの70人は
「痛い 痛い」と言って
10人ぐらいはもうそこらじゅう
転げ回って大騒ぎします
これは持って生まれた
性格だと思うのですが
その後その100人のうち１人の
堂々とした人格ある子どもが
必ずしも立派な...
いわゆる一般に言う
「性格の良い大人」になっていくとは
限らないです
これは何でこうなるのでしょうか？
長老）そういうのは
生まれつきであるか分からないね
周りの環境やら
子どもの場合は
親があまりにも下手で
子どもが間違っている場合もあるし
だから洗脳的に痛くなる
ということもあるし
母親に洗脳されていて
母親も知らないのですけど
別に注射は痛くないのだけど
本当は...
私も注射を打ってもらう場合
私には面白いのはお医者さんが
この間 医者が注射を打ったのだけど
向こうはすごい痛い顔をするのです
私の代わりに先生が
痛い顔をしているのだから
まあこれで十分だと（笑）
だから 子どもの場合でも
理性で子育てをすると
それはなくなりますよ
日常は 遊んだりする時でも
子どもは寝転がったり
痛がったりするでしょう
今度注射を打ちますけど
あれは あなた
この間転んだでしょう？
あの痛みから まあ...
100分の１ぐらい痛いのですけど
子どもは先に怪我したり
転がったり
「痛い！」と泣いていたり
あんなのの100分の１ぐらいかなとか
それでも おしっこたらして
泣きたければ どうぞ
と言う風に言えば 絶対泣かないよ
私はものすごく小さい時
小学校４年ぐらいで
親指をケガしたのです
兄貴と遊んでいて
潰されたのです 親指が
今もこの傷跡があるのだけど
病院に連れて行かれたら
生（なま）でこれを全部
この潰れた肉を
切ってしまったのです
私はまだ小さくて
父親が抱っこをしていて
病院のベッドに寝かせたら
医者が来て
ハサミを持って
これはかなり潰れているのだと
生（なま）で肉をチリチリチリと
切ってしまったのです
（せめて）痛み止めぐらい
注射しても良い（会場笑）
そんなこと私は子どもだから
分からないでしょうに
医者はとにかく
父親と 病院で仕事をする
友だちがいたのだから
とにかくここをつないで
おいてくださいと
あまりにも小さいのだから
他の薬とか
使いたくなかったことも
あるでしょうね
そこで医者か看護師か
誰かが言うのは
「あなた 男の子だから
強いですね」とか
「ああ 男の子だから大丈夫
泣かないでしょうね」とか
あれに乗っちゃったのです
だからハサミで切ると
「うう！」と
すごく痛かったのです
それを２～３回...
４回ぐらいやったのです
しょうがないでしょう
男だから泣く訳にもいかない
だからそんなもので
ちょっとしたことで
性格変わりますよ
だから ずっと
人の性格は変わらない...
と思わないでください
環境によって 教え方によって
いつでも変わるのです
だからすごく「性格」というのは
転がりやすいのです
簡単に変化するのです
だから「女心と秋の空」とか
何とかいうフレーズがありますね
これは「性格」にしてください
すぐ変わるものなのです
女性を差別するために
使うのではなくて
ですから どうせ性格は
不安定で変わるものだから
良い性格に変わるように
とするのです
それでプーチンさんが
断然悪人とか
いろいろ例に出ましたけど
私はそういう風に判断しないのです
私は今プーチンさんのことを
しゃべっていても
まずテレビのニュースを見ない
ネットでも そういう
news information ありますけど
読まない
気に入らない
どう見ても
偏ったニュースだから
しかし 戦争で被害を受けるのは
どちらでも被害を受けているのです
これは人間でしょうに
苦労して作った財産でしょうに
それが何で
阿呆かと
私はウクライナ人であろうか
ロシア人であろうか
どうでも良いのです
こいつらもう阿呆も良いところだと
人殺ししなくても良いでしょう
という態度だから
でも 性格の問題で
戦争を引き起こしてしまって
まあプーチンさんにも...
分からないのだけど
それなりに...
良いところもあるかもね
分からない...
まあ リーダーシップを
無理やり取る人は
根本的に性格悪い
それは普遍的なのです
リーダーになってやろう
権力者になってやろうと思ったら
そちらでその人には
精神的な問題があるのです
だから世にある権力者たちは
みんな...
やっぱりカウンセリングを
受けた方が良いのです
私には理解できない
何で権力者になりたがるのですかね？
みんなと一緒に行った方が
一番楽しくて良いのに
平等でいた方が何でも頼めるのに
権力者になったら
そこはちょっと変になりますね
だからみんな頭が素晴らしく
ものの見事に 悪いのだから
「権力者」という言葉は
あるのです 世の中で
私は仏教的に言うのは
「マネージャー」なのです
我々に「権力者」は...
一切要らない
精神的な病気だから
我々に必要なのは
「マネージャー」なのです
なぜなら 10人集めたら
誰かがまとめ役をやらなくては
いけないでしょう
まとめ役をやったからといって
偉そうな権力者ではないでしょうに
だから日本の国のCEOは
総理大臣の名前は...
会場の方）岸田（首相）...
長老）岸田さん
権力者ではなくて
マネージャー CEOなのです
もし仕事をうまくやらなかったら
クビにします
マネージング・ヘッド
（※管理責任者）だったら
だから家族の中でも
男性が偉いか 女性が偉いか
ではなくて
Who is the good manager?
女性の方がすごい良い
マネージャーだったら
あの家族で女性がトップ
この家族で何か女の人が
遊んだり いろいろお化粧したり
服を探したり カバンを探したりとか
そういう性格だったら
マネージングには行かない
そこを男性がマネージングする
だから世に必要なのは
マネージャーなのです
学校の教師が権力者ですかね？
マネージャーでしょうに
今日も私は電車の改札口に入ると
幡ヶ谷駅でも
小っちゃな子どもたちが
何か服装を着て
たくさんのグループが
ギャーギャーと言いながら
出ているのです
子どもたちはすごく行儀よく
遊んでふざけるのは
子どもたちの仕事だから
一人か二人は先に出てしまって
もう一人が改札口を出ないで
ここからギャーギャーと言ったりとか
ややこしい状態で
それをちょっと見ていると
ギャーッと喋りながら
誰か他の人が来たのです
その先生でしょうね 恐らく
だから その先生が
マネージャーなのです
子どもたちは自由に
電車から下りて 改札口を出て
右に曲がって みんな
行きたい所に行くのです
でも 20人ぐらいいるのだから
先生も一緒に行くのです
まとめ役は先生がやるのです
「ちょっと待ってよ」とか
「みんな揃うまで
あなたこちらにいなさい」とか
あれは権力者ではないでしょう？
家で母親に一人の子どもを
管理できないのだけど
あの人々は
20人 30人ちゃんと管理しているのです
だから世の中で権力者というのは
消した方が
うまく行くと思いますよ
私たちに必要なのは
マネージャーたちなのです
マネージャーはどうしても
何人かはマネージメントする
会社があっても 工場があっても
マネージャーがいないと
成り立たないでしょうに
動物ではないのだからね
そういうことで
マネージング能力も
ロクにないくせに
権力を誇示すると言えば
やっぱり病院行きでしょう
みんな
かわいそう この世界は
なぜなら精神的にいかれている人々が
政権を取っているのだから
自分の国の大統領はもう明確に
精神的な病気なのです
あのシゾフレニア（統合失調症）
あのやり方を見ると
これはどんな国でも
ヨーロッパはそれほどないですけど
ごく普通の女の人が
総理大臣になったりとか
いるのだけど
他はちょっと...
それは脱線した話で
あまり意味がないのだけど
人はいろいろ性格は持っているのです
それはもうどうにもならない
仕方がないことで
人と言えば自分の性格もあります
「性格」というのは
固定したものではなくて
その場で その場で
すごく柔軟に変わるものなのです
だから 性格は粘土みたいに
子どもたちが遊ぶ時に使う
何かグニャグニャするもの
ありますね 粘土でもなくて
会場の方）スライムですか？
長老）その何とかという...
缶に入っていて
これはいろんな形にすることが
できるのです
性格ってそういう風に
どんな形にも入れるように
なった方が良いのです
これは「性格が変わった」
ではなくて...
頑固ということでもないのです
良く言う「TPO」です
以上です
司会の方）スマナサーラ長老
どうもありがとうございました
お時間となりましたので
本日の初期仏教講演会は
ここで終わらせて頂きます
長老）では 祝福の偈を唱えますので
合掌してください
Sabbītiyo vivajjantu sabba rogo vinassatu
サッビーティヨー ヴィワッジャントゥ
サッバ ローゴー ヴィナッサトゥ
一切の不幸・病苦を避けられますように
Mā te bhavatvantarāyo
マー テー バワトゥワンタラーヨー
災難に遭うことなく
sukhī dīghāyuko bhava.
スキー ディーガーユコー バワ
皆が末永く幸福に暮らせますように
Bhavatu sabba maṅgalaṃ
バワトゥ サッバ マンガラン
すべての祝福がありますように
rakkhantu sabba devata
ラッカントゥ サッバ デーワター
諸天善神のご加護がありますように
Sabba buddhānubhāvena
サッバ ブッダーヌバーヴェーナ
佛（ブッダ）の威徳によって
Sabba dhammānubhāvena
サッバ ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ
法（ダンマ）の威徳によって
Sabba sanghānubhāvena
サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ
僧（サンガ）の威徳によって
sadā sotthī bhavantu te
サダー ソッティー バワントゥ テー
皆が常に平安でありますように
Āyurārogiya sampatti,
長寿と健康を保つこと
sagga sampattimevaca.
天界に生まれること
Atho nibbāna sampatti,
そして涅槃に達すること
iminā te samijjhatu.
これらの皆さんの願いが
叶えられますように
ありがとうございます
長い時間 休憩もなしに
大変申し訳ございません
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
了